laurent degousée co délégué du syndicat
sud commerce à l'origine de la plainte
bonjour monsieur dégoût et merci d'être
avec nous alors tout d'abord qu'est ce
qui a motivé votre plainte ce qui a
motivé notre plainte c'est tout
simplement ce qu'ont constaté au niveau
sanitaire chez amazon depuis maintenant
trois semaines c'est à dire des salariés
qui présentait les symptômes du corona
virus puis des salariés qui étaient
testés positifs au co vite 19 h et puis
à l'heure où nous parlons toujours l'un
d'entre eux qui est en réanimation
voilà donc ça veut dire qu amazon ne
respectait pas du tout les mesures
d'hygiène et de sécurité a préconisé par
le gouvernement
ce n'est pas ton que amazon ne
respectait pas moi je ne dis pas que
amazon n'a rien fait depuis trois
semaines mais il faut on a tous en tête
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un entrepôt
amazon vous avez une promiscuité
considérable avec des centaines de
travailleurs douce comprends pas c'est
que dans le même temps vous avez
gouvernement qui est interdit par décret
les activités de plus de 100 personnes
et que dans l'autre pour des activités
qui pour la plupart peuvent être
discutables
on continue à faire travailler les
salariés comme si de rien n'était et
qu'à la fin maroc ce virus que leur
santé est compromise voire le cas
échéant c'est déjà arrivé dans la grande
distribution ou dans l'insécurité qu'ils
en meurent dont on allait chez
simplement d'agir en responsabilité on a
du mal un peu à comprendre
amazon 1 parce qu'au début après 7,7
décision du tribunal de nanterre où
clairement il était dit que amazon
devait livrer exclusivement des produits
alimentaires ou d'hygiène donc des
produits essentiels amazon avait un peu
à montrer son désaccord et quelques
heures plus tard elle dit non finalement
on envisage de suspendre totalement
l'activité en france pourquoi un tel
revirement
parce que nous c'est ce qu'on dénonce
depuis début août beaucoup beaucoup
d'effets d'affichage je vais donner un
exemple à vos téléspectateurs hayon
amazon nous dit nous on va plus loin que
ce que préconise le gouvernement
la distance sociale chez nous elle est
de 2 mètres et pas d'un mètre sauf qu'il
a été prouvé et compris par l'inspection
du travail que cette distance ne pouvait
pas la tenir
vous devez régulièrement la casse et je
vais donner un exemple vous avez un
colis de plus de 25 kilos vous avez
besoin de deux salariés pour le porter
alors sauf à avoir la taille d'un
basketteur
ils vont nécessairement être en contact
les uns les autres donc d'une certaine
manière amazon va plus loin que ce que
dit la décision d'hier même s'ils nous
ont demandé à titre principal
la fermeture c'est bien qu'ils
reconnaissent que la nature même de
l'activité ne permet pas sauf à
rhabiller les salariés ont tenues de
cosmonautes à éviter la propagation de
ce virus donc d'une certaine manière
trois semaines après et on peut que les
en féliciter même s'il a fallu les ans
contraindre amazon choisi la voie de la
raison donc on espère que les quelques
jours parce qu'attention aura pas de
fermeture définitive on pas de fermeture
temporaire le temps de quoi c'est aussi
ce que dick tribunal le temps d'évaluer
les la portée des mesures de sécurité
mises en place
peut-être faut-il en nombre et certaines
petites fautes elle les modifier
peut-être faut-il en rajouter non en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on dit depuis le
début on est plus à quitter la société
pour peu qu'elle se décide enfin à agir
de manière loyale
les entrepôts amazon en france pas
fermer définitivement mais en tout cas
temporairement on sait comment ça se
passe les salariés sont alors mis au
chômage partiel au chômage technique
c'est donc le contribuable français
l'état français qui va payer ses
salariés
est ce que pour vous c'est un peu normal
que ce soit l'état français qui paient
les salariés d'une entreprise comme
amazon en c1 entreprises et la plus
riche au monde est plutôt très forte en
optimisation fiscale vous en pensez quoi
pas nécessairement je pense
qu'effectivement les de la responsabilté
d'amazon qui d'une certaine manière n'a
cherché qu'à repousser cette solution
d'indemniser à hauteur de 100%
ces salariés je vais parler d'une autre
multinationale par exemple apple
1 qu'est une capitalisation boursière
supérieure à celle d' amazon et apple a
fait savoir non seulement 1 qui fermé
leurs magasins
mais qui dès qu'ils indemniseraient de
leur propre poche à hauteur de 100%
le personnel donc moi j'invite la
société amazon effectivement à avoir la
même politique vertueuse je l'invite
aussi vous aviez dans la période
de nombreux salariés qui ont fait valoir
leur droit de retrait on a toujours une
difficulté à cet effet avec la société
c'est qu'évidemment on estime suite à la
décision du tribunal judiciaire
et puis suite aux mises en demeure qui
est ton qui ont été adressées par à
l'inspection du travail que l' usage du
droit de retrait par les salariés ce
n'est pas juste
l'esprit il était largement justifié
donc amazon l'a aussi se grandirait à
dire écoutez j'ai bien compris que
j'avais des lacunes je vais tâcher de
les réparer et donc je vais y compris
verser le salaire qui étaient suspendues
pendant la durée du droit de retrait de
mon personnel l'eau rendez vous et merci
d'avoir et en direct avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes cours délégué du
syndicat sud commerce merci d'avoir été
en direct